Un día como hoy pero en 1947 con la
herida del holocausto aún abierta
Naciones Unidas tomó una decisión
histórica el plan de partición de
Palestina en un estado judío y un estado
árabe
la resolución del comité sobre Palestina
fue adoptada por 33 votos 13 en contra y
10 abstenciones
una medida que israelíes apoyaron y los
árabes rechazaron por algo que ya
preveían hace 75 años que se estado
árabe nunca llegaría y que creían
Injusto ya que a pesar de representar un
tercio de la población el plan les daba
a los judíos casi la mitad del
territorio algo que desencadenó en uno
de los conflictos más largo de nuestros
tiempos la creación del estado de Israel
y su primera guerra con Palestina con
enfrentamientos a miles de muertes y El
Éxodo de cerca de 700.000 palestinos que
siguen hasta a día de hoy sin ir más
lejos Este martes tres jóvenes
palestinos mu a manos del ejército de
israelí cerca de ramala y hebrón
sumándose a los cerca de 150 palestinos
muertos en lo que va de año
[Aplausos]
Esto es una prueba de que la arrogancia
de la ocupación no distingue entre
estudiantes o ancianos no hay respeto
por la humanidad
una situación es que el actual
secretario general de la ONU Antonio
Gutiérrez tacha de insostenible
insto a todas las partes a tomar medidas
inmediatas para reducir las tensiones y
poner fin a la espiral de violencia que
envuelve a la cisjordania ocupada en
este día de Palestina reafirmemos
nuestro apoyo al pueblo palestino en su
búsqueda para construir un futuro de paz
justicia seguridad y dignidad para todos
y es que ese prometido estado palestino
está más lejos de hacerse realidad que
nunca con cada vez más pérdida de
territorio desde 1947 algunas ong temen
que incluso termine totalmente
anexionado por Israel todo en el medio
de las demandas de una investigación
independiente sobre la ocupación a la
que Israel se niega